hello everyone and welcome back to
Scotland we are back at the lenders
Abbey the whiskey distillery and it's
Dingley rent versus Vishwanathan Anand
it's a really an amazing game really an
inspiring game I really hope you enjoy
it I really enjoyed it and you can learn
a lot from it before we check out the
game I do have a very short announcement
yesterday I played well not yesterday
the past three days I was playing a
chess tournament I was able to win all
games and I have won my candidate master
title here's my shiny trophy there have
it here's the nice trophy and like I
said some time ago I don't really play
in chess tournaments especially not a
low-rated tournaments but I was able to
win I think from the last 20 games I
played in the creation League and in my
chess club championship out of the I
think out of the 20 games let's say I
think I won nineteen I only lost one and
no draws so that was a that was very
nice and Indian the end result was that
I was able to cross the 2020 100 rate
rating threshold in the in Croatia
national rating so I was well I think it
will be of version that I will be
awarded the candid master title so that
was I mean it's a I'm very happy about
that just you know sharing that with you
guys but there that being said let's
check out this very nice game
ding has the white pieces and he opens
with c4 we have E 5 and g3 and some of
you have already asked on other social
media will I be showing any games from
this tournament I will I will show some
after we finish with this with this
tournament and the D we finish the Grand
Prix then maybe we can show a show of
you Knight to f6 by Anand with Bishop to
g2 and now comes c6 preparing d5 with
Knight to f3 and now comes a for pushing
guy back on and grabs more space in the
center nice the d4 and d5 here we have
d3 defending the c4 pawn but also
challenging the e4 pawn and Bishop to c5
here nice to be 3 and Anand pushes back
with Bishop Tibet to be 6 but it's also
very
interesting I mean the it doesn't work
here but you always have to check out
Bishop captures an f2 in some positions
it will work and you never know for
example here but your capture screen
captures and III is very nice I mean of
course the Hindu king will not capture
if the King captures then you can get a
lot of I mean nice moves in as the King
is already on e3 but even if the King
doesn't capture let's say you play
Bishop captures on e3 then Knight to g4
will be deadly
I mean now the King has to go up the
board to defend the bishop and after
here I can go but Queen to f6 check
official blogs then you get the g5 in
and black gets an excellent game but of
course it doesn't work because after
Bishop capture screen captures in d3 the
White King can just go back when taking
g1 and now you can even block with d4
and it will be somewhat hard for whites
to develop but it's no real compensation
especially not in such a such a long
game like this a 25 minute rapid game +
10 seconds increment but you know 4
bullet perfectly viable but ok after
Knight to b3 we have Bishop the back to
pieces by Anand and now C capture son b5
and there are two games in the database
for seek after sandy v was played but
here on and goes Queen captures on d5
and it is already from move 8 that we
have a completely new game on our hands
so what do you do here seems a bit odd
to put your Queen on on this diagonal
but Anand came prepared for for this
game we have castles by dink and now
comes Queen to f5 you do have to move
the Queen as Knight to c3 is coming
either way so better make it now we have
Knight to c3 by dink and now e captures
on d3 and now if you capture then you
will have to play with the isolated pawn
for the rest of the game so here being
finds a different way to recapture first
efore pushes back the Queen we have
Queen to h5 now offering a queen trade
and now you have two straight Queens and
you will win the d3 pawn later if you
play this then black has a lot of ideas
here he can go Bishop to h3 he can
castle he can go Knight to g4 he already
has a beautiful Bishop and on B 6 so not
something the thing is interested in
playing against talent so here he just
captures with Queen captures Knight
captures and now rook to d1 preparing to
recaptured
very nice pass pawn here Knight back to
f6 and now comes Knight to a4 attacking
on the bishop and here
I don't know Bishop here seems like a
very nice move if you want to keep your
bishop pair like rush up to c7 I would
get an IBC 5 and then if you push the
bishop the knight back then just Knight
capture some d3 and so on but you do get
to keep your bishop pair and that has a
different plan he he's not interested in
keeping the bishop pair he says ok if
you capture I'm gonna play a capture
some b6 I'm gonna get to the semi open
the file for my rook and I'm gonna play
this game so nice to a6 on and keeps
developing pieces we have rook captures
and III finally recapturing the pawn and
now Bishop to e6
we have Knight captures and b6 now a cat
person b6 and now just a3 controlling
the squares that this black knight can
use that entered the game and but now c5
here Anand is preparing c4 which would
of course win material we have Knights
to d2 blocking this and now c4 would see
four would be met with rook to d6 it's a
very nice idea just attacking the b6
pawn and now if b v e5 wins the game it
would be unfortunate for unattended like
this 97 Bishop captures you're gonna
well the knight is attacked you can move
the knight and lose lose the exchange or
you can move the rook lose I lose a full
piece but it's just not good so here at
night the b4 Allen finds a very
interesting idea he attacks the rook and
of course the bishop is stolen developed
the rocks aren't connected this rook is
undefended so you cannot capture due to
this pin here and the King has to play
something he plays the rook to c3 and
now comes Knights to a 2 by anna not
attacking this rook and now you have
some problems if you if you just move
the rook for example go to d3 or to see
to Alan can just repeat moose night
before attack the rook would go back
with the night and night before go back
with the night and I don't know it's a
he has the black pieces against dink I
don't know if maybe if the position
would would be
repeated here or not but Bing doesn't
allow him to do that first we have to
also check out the rook to f3 it's a
weird place for the rook to be as it
blocks the bishop but also black can
just go queenside castle and now the
rook the knight is under attack
if Knight captures on c1 then you would
even eliminate the defender of the d2
night white would lose a piece and if
Knights the b3 trying to get the night
out of the way it doesn't work because
it was just rook to d1 check Bishop
blocks and now you remove the defender
Bishop captures and b3 so the bishop and
c1 is no longer guarded twice rook
captures and now Knight captures and c1
just wins the rock is under attack if
you move it then the other rook is lost
92 check route captures rook captures on
a1 and so on and so on
and black is up a whole look at the end
of this very nice variation so after a
night to 8:00 to dink says okay rook
captures on a two he gives up the
exchange temporarily but after Bishop
captures he plays b3 and he says okay
your Bishop is not leaving this prison
at some point I will win it and then I
will just have two pieces for a rook
which of course will equal a winning
game Alan says all right we have Queen
side castles and now what do you do here
first
ding plays d5 freeze this bishop to
control this very long diagonal we have
Knights - eh no trades are really in
favor of Anand as he does have to keep
an eye on his pieces now Knights the e8
and now Bishop the h3 check-writing
weave King to c7 and here Bishop back to
f1 here ding isn't interested in rook to
c2 rook the see-through rook to c2 is a
really complicated line and I haven't
seen the interview if evening was
considering it but it's it's really a
wonderful line first black will capture
the night rook capture Sundy to rook
captures and Bishop captures and b3 and
now you've given back the exchange but
you can go rook to d7 check King to c6
and now rook to e7 this is the hard move
to find threatening the Bishop to d7
check here to win material and then you
would have to go Knights e7 and then
finally Bishop to d7 check
King has to go to d5 and now you grabbed
upon here rook captures you get King
captors and e5 rook captures and g7 and
you get this position where it's four
points against for a White's pawn
structure is a little bit better due to
blacks double pawns here and white does
have the bishop pair so white would be
better in this endgame but being says I
can do even better than that I'm gonna
prepare it first the bishop to c1 sorry
to F 1 with f6 trying to break break up
this chain get the knight back into the
game and now e 6 ding isn't interested
in creates a passed pawn here we have
Knight to d6 by Annan and now only rook
to c2 that now that the knight has
blocked the rope you cannot go for this
same idea we have Bishop captures on b3
Knight captures on b3 and not rook hd8
and here you can see that ding now one
two pieces for the rook and Anand has an
item two rooks against a rock knight and
a bishop pair so it will be very hard
for Arnold to play this we have a four
by ding preparing a5 you want to remove
the defender of the c5 pawn and then if
that falls well it will be very nice for
white we have rook captures and e6 and
now comes a five we see four by Anand
attacking the knight here now comes
Bishop captures on c4 Knight captures on
c4 we have rook after some c4 with check
and now rook the c6 blocking and hoping
to well maybe even maybe even fix the
pawn structure but we have Bishop to f4
check by ding King to d7 and now comes
Luke the b4 well hoping to win a pawn
here B captures on a five-night captures
on 85 and out Knights to a6 and here
Dean just captures we have rook after
Sun b7
king te 8 and now first you have to do
something about the night before you go
upon grabbing Knight to b3 and here
Annan goes King to f8 he doesn't allow
this point to be captured and h4 biding
so
Allen's king is pushed back all the way
to the eighth rank he still has the two
rooks but the the Bishop Knight and rook
will be well will be tough tough to
parry here in this endgame
we have looked at eh by Anand and now
comes Knight to d4 we have rooked
seven offering a trade of rooks and
which tried to hold with rook against
the bishop and night since all of his
bones are intact and it's still a very
nice pawn chain but the ding isn't
interested we have Ruby a check King to
f7 and now comes Knight to f5 attacking
the rook rook to d7 you know you can't
move the rook from the seventh rank den
Broek b7 will be very strong
so rook to b7 and now comes h5 preparing
h6 and now we have looked a five so just
rook 285 attacking the knight if the
knight moves it will also attack the
pawn here so nice to d6 check first we
have King to e6 and now comes Knight the
b5 blocking the rooks attack the world's
the pawn king to f5 now and already you
can see that Anand has some devious
plans of king g4 king of three and Luke
d1 checkmate would be very nice if he
can get this in budgeting of course
blocks it we have King to g2 King to g4
now f3 not really working as this would
lose you the h5 pawn so with h6 and now
not trading but rather g5 pushing the
bishop back King h5 followed by captures
is unexplained next with Bishop back to
e3 and now comes King to h5 and here we
have looked the b6 saying okay you
capture this I'm gonna capture that on
and says no thank you first I'm gonna go
King to g6 and only next move after this
point is sufficiently defended will I
maybe capture on h6 and here you have to
be very careful you can go something
like Bishop d4 this would lose material
you are threatening to win here but then
just real capture some b5 captures
captures and you will then play black
would even win a pawn but it would be
basically a drawing rooks endgame so
after King to g6
probably the best for fording will be
King to h3 just keeping the tension and
after what makes a move let's say rook
d3 go Knight d4 and you know keep
everything as it is just enjoying your
advantage and trying to improve little
by little but here ding plays g4 and it
does prevent the black King from
entering any deeper into the position
but it also gives out on the target so
first rook to a 4
attacking the g4 pawn king to g3 but
this rook to e4 was a crucial so crucial
tempo that allows Anand to create
something beautiful here feel free to
pause the video and try to find the best
move for black I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations it's just just
a magnificent move and I don't think
ding even realized that it was there but
when I won played it I'm sure he didn't
feel all that well anymore but for those
of you you know we were able to do it
really congratulations
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook the before and here just
everything is so beautiful you can't
move the rook if you move the rook you
lose the night if you lose the night if
sorry if you move the knight you can I
mean you can't move the knight this is
taken by the rook this is taken by the
rock it doesn't really matter if the
rook is protected but all these scores
are covered by the rook these squares
are also covered by the rock d4 square
is covered by both rooks so that's not
possible and if you try Knight c3 or
night a3 doesn't really matter then just
a rook captures Bishop captures and rook
to d3 check will pick up the night you
can walk with the bishop robe chapters
you will eliminate this point and black
has a completely winning endgame on the
other hand if you try something like
rook to b8 just waiting and see what
happens then black continues King
captures here rook to b6 King to g6
and then you can just either repeat but
probably would have to go sound like
rook to d6 rook captures Knight captures
and then you would have to play out the
same game and this would be unknown
would be able to hold this three points
against two rook against Bishop tonight
would be able to hold this to a draw but
here ding played King to f3 he finds a
different plan he says not going to move
anything but knock on and finds another
excellent move rook to d3 and now it's
even better because now the knight
cannot move to a7 or c7 because well if
you try something like this just rook
captures the bishop is now pinned you
cannot recapture so it's a really hard
to find a move
and the best idea for fording would be
would have been rook to d6 and this is
the only move possible because rook to
b3 is such a such a terrible threat here
with rook to d6 it would be possible to
continue it but now you of course get
rook captures on e3 and then after F
captures on e3 Roccat force on b5 and
you get this Roxanne game three against
three
what blacks bone structure a little bit
better but it should be a draw here
after rook the d3 ding played rook to b8
he says I wanna untangle here by giving
this check and then I'm gonna move the
knight on and says no thank you first
King captures on a6 and now Dean just
repeats we have worked the b6 back on
and repeats King to g6 and here Anand
finally manages the trick ding and take
you know grab the driver's seat in this
for a very long time who were send game
here Dean's last option is rook to d6
just going into this trade that we
already explained but here thing just
repeated rook to b8 hoping that Aaron
will just repeat King to h6 and you know
it's it's a draw but here on and says no
it's not rook to b3 it seems that Dean
just forgot about this move but he was a
very low on time and maybe he thought
that he this would still be manageable
some some way because Dean play rook to
g8 check King to f7 and now Luke to h8
saying okay I'm gonna give you the night
then I'm gonna grab this with check and
okay I mean it's two points against two
points two rooks against rook and Bishop
but how are you gonna break this I mean
there's no way to break this I will be
able to hold this with white but here on
and tried so her so long to play this
worse end game and manage to get a
superior position he says I'm not even
giving you this slight chance of a draw
King to g7 and here it was in this
position unmoved 55 that being clear and
resigned to the game so a beautiful game
against Anand really an interesting game
for sting to lose a lot of time with
that rook to eight to maneuver sir
Knight way to maneuver how will he
untangle there and in the end the ding
was didn't play the brilliant game he
was able to trap Allen tonight he wanted
without losing anything
well but it's not enough you have to
play the game out until the end play
play it perfectly and that's what I
earned it and continue playing like you
know everything was everything was just
fine and in the end he prevailed and
that's how you should play chess you
know it's there's nothing worse than
when someone you know gets a worse
position and then you start feeling bad
and then you start playing bad moves you
should always play you know your
opponent will not play a perfect game
your opponent is not a machine and then
you will have to wait for opportunity
and just you know do what under did here
here there's nothing anymore to do
because after we move the rook rook e8
or roof to d8 it doesn't really matter
black will just capture the night and
then you have three points against you
but now it's completely different this
is not a completely winning endgame due
to black having this extra pawn yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
we're gonna be covering one more game
from this chest our saloon doors abbey
whiskey distillery tournament and then
we're gonna check out the standings as
we are we do have one excellent game
that we are going to show and yeah like
I said I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Martin Oakenfold David
Turnbull Luca Lamberty Jasper Hodge and
B by enroll if gbr for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos your think all for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content you know you know how it is I
think y'all I will see soon in her annex
on rest of your Monday